KEVIN CHIAO: So I
translated some of these
so that they're more English
friendly for you guys,
so they might sound
kind of weird.
The first question--
and this is for more
of the games in Korea and
Japan and the United States--
is, what are the characteristics
of a successful game for you
guys?
Anyone can start.
KH?
Kho?
KOH KIM: You want me to start?
I'll start.
Successful game.
Ultimately, it needs
to be fun, right?
KEVIN CHIAO: Basically.
KOH KIM: Hey, people over there.
I'm kidding.
Well, it needs to be a fun game.
I think a lot of it is
that games, especially
on our mobile platforms,
have definitely been-- I
mean, you've seen
the explosive growth.
You've seen how it
has evolved and how
it's evolved very quickly.
I still remember
three, four years ago
when "Angry Birds" was
the game, but now you're
seeing a lot more complicated,
a lot more complex, deeply
immersive games that you thought
you would see on PC five,
six years ago, and
it's possible now.
So just the strength
of the hardware,
mobile broadband penetration,
and in general, just
people's ability to
develop all these
really interesting and
high quality experiences
for a mobile device, but in
the end, a game has to be fun.
Match 3 is nothing new.
Strategy is nothing new.
RPGs are not new.
They've existed
20, 30 years ago.
It's ultimately,
how do you present
that in a way that's deeply
engaging and fun to the users
and players of today?
KH MIN: I agree with Kho that
definitely, high quality,
great content is the number one.
But I would like to mention
that the [INAUDIBLE] games,
I think it needs to be local.
Hard corers, I think the local
event is much more important,
rather than having some
local specific characters.
For example, [INAUDIBLE], when
they launched their games,
they're really focusing on
doing some local events,
so they really want to
engage with hard core users
after they install the games.
That event was very
successful, and now
they still continue to
invest in that local event.
HIROTAKA YOSHITUGU:
And also, adding
the new functions to the mobile
users from the user perspective
looks like 3 Match
games in the market,
there are tons of
the 3 Match games,
so how they decided to use the
3 Match game is just IP stuff.
Or it's more like it looks
fun or something like that.
But once the game
has unique functions,
like a match player
near the friends,
then that makes it more unique
in the market in the game side.
That's making it fun,
making the users,
and making revenue as well.
That's the things, I guess.
KOH KIM: Another thing you
have to really think about
is it's all about
your community.
Your players are your
biggest advocates,
are the ones that are going
to go tell their other friends
to play this game.
I think it's probably
even mandatory.
I don't think it's
a characteristic.
I now think it's a requirement.
How do you build a game
that's a service, that's
something that's kind of like
will build that relationship
with the player?
If you look at some
of the top games that
are in any of these
markets, probably outside
of more of the emerging
and newer markets,
is that a lot of these
games have been around
for multiple years.
And that success has been
built upon their ability
to really understand who their
players are and what they want
and to actually iterate
and update the games
and optimize it based on what
the players are asking for.
So that sense of community
and building a community
is going to be very important.
KEVIN CHIAO: Thanks, guys.
This next question is for Tony
on Google Play Game Services.
What kind of things
do we need to look out
for in terms of a successful
Google Play Game Services
integration?
You could talk about more the
technical API stuff or you can
also talk about just in general
for Google Play Game Services,
too.
TONY CHAN: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
KEVIN CHIAO: Play Game Services.
HIROTAKA YOSHITUGU:
One good example
from the Japanese market is
[INAUDIBLE] using crowd saving.
It's not actually a
Play Game Services,
but they are using
crowd saving for saving
the data on the Android,
as well as on the iOS.
So users actually are using the
data on the Android and iOS,
so that's a good example of
the Play Game Services as well.
KH MIN: And again,
[INAUDIBLE] is
one of the successful
cases of a going
global project from Korea.
They gave us very
interesting numbers.
They are implementing two APIs.
One is their own API,
and the other one
is Google Play Game Services.
And they're saying
that actually, they're
very successful globally,
and more than around 80%,
they are using Google
Play Game Services.
To make users interact
within their games,
I think that Google Play Game
Service is very effective.
I think with a global
market, and if you
think of more than
a billion Android
users as your
customers, then you
need to think about
Google Play Game Services.
KEVIN CHIAO: KH, this
one's more for you.
Could you talk about
like opportunities,
because you talk about Com2uS
a lot, and a lot of developers
are probably
wondering, how do we
get the same type
of opportunities
to work with Google Play?
Like in Korea, they
use Com2uS and Japan,
we work very closely with Mixi.
If you want to go
into detail about how
they go about being able to
have these opportunities to work
so closely with Google Play.
KH MIN: [INAUDIBLE] marketing?
KEVIN CHIAO: On the marketing
side, those kinds of things.
HIROTAKA YOSHITUGU:
Relationship side.
KEVIN CHIAO: Relationships.
Yeah.
So you could talk about the
co-promotion with gift cards
and stuff like that.
KH MIN: Everyone is talking
about featuring games,
featuring applications
within the Google Play Store.
I think that is one of
our in store marketing,
but we are also helping our
great content at Google Play
to be shown out of store.
For example, when we
launched the Google Play gift
card in Hong Kong,
we worked with Com2uS
and then our marketing teams.
And then actually, we
wrapped the CVS in Hong Kong.
We featured our Google Play gift
card and their games offline.
Actually, the campaign
was super successful,
and then we launched our
Google Play gift card in Korea
in November.
And then actually, we wrapped
the pillars of the major subway
stations with Google Play
gift card and game titles.
Actually, we really want
to try to provide some out
of store marketing
opportunities for our developers
once you develop really,
really great content.
HIROTAKA YOSHITUGU: It's
almost the same in Japan, too.
Good contents bring
in the good users,
and we like to encourage
those contents to expand
to more users.
KH MIN: Same in Taiwan
and Hong Kong as well.
We also do a lot with Six Waves,
we did a promo code campaign,
where they went to Ocean
Park and handed out.
Tony, you can probably talk
more about that if you want.
TONY CHAN: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
KEVIN CHIAO: This
question is for Koh.
What are common strategies
for successfully launching
a game in a Western market?
We call EUAME, which is
a combination of Europe
and America.
KOH KIM: Well, it's really
not that much different.
Here in Japan, in
Korea and Asia,
you see a lot more out of
home and all that stuff,
and actually, I'm slowly seeing
a lot of that in the United
States as well.
A lot of these game
companies are coming out
with much bigger
marketing campaigns
that's largely online.
But it ultimately is
really finding out
and getting user feedback
directly because a lot
of these users do live online.
And so it's just finding
the right communities,
the right sources and channels
to touch in and figure out,
hey, how am I going to get
the users to install the game,
and also how am I going to
continue to engage users
in a way to get them to
feel empowered to talk more
about my game?
So looking at what your
social mechanics are
within the game in
terms of orality
and how people are
going to share content
and their progress
to other players,
also hitting the
right communities,
whether it's on Reddit
or if it's on YouTube,
or whether that's on Twitch.
There's tons of other,
all of these video game
focused communities that a
lot of these players are on.
So it's just really
understanding your own game
genre [INAUDIBLE].
Clearly, you want to make sure
that whatever your users are
going to share is going to
be very relevant to the game
but also is going to be engaging
or attractive to other users.
Within the US, a lot of
it's online marketing.
I've seen some interesting
things done with video
in terms of video sharing,
live streaming, also
work with more of the YouTube
stars and celebrities.
So a lot of it is just
understanding just
like any user, the
users live online.
It's just finding out
where online they see,
and then making sure your
game is in that channel.
HIROTAKA YOSHITUGU:
Video sharing
is getting bigger in the US?
KOH KIM: Oh yeah.
It's very big in the US.
HIROTAKA YOSHITUGU:
Is it common?
KOH KIM: It's pretty common.
HIROTAKA YOSHITUGU: Do you
have to implement video sharing
functions?
KOH KIM: It's not
have to, but videos
tend to convert users a lot
higher than still images.
HIROTAKA YOSHITUGU:
How about Korea?
KH MIN: The YouTube
creators, actually they
are developing
their own content.
Individual content creators,
they're introducing games,
and they're playing
games, and they're
sharing that video clips.
It's getting super,
super popular.
So actually, the
YouTube creators,
they are becoming celebrities.
We figured out,
many gamers, they
are watching that kind of
video, and it's a great way
of engaging with the users.
HIROTAKA YOSHITUGU: In Japan,
YouTube is getting popular,
and also, video sharing function
is getting popular, too.
Some top level players implement
the share function or the share
videos, playing videos.
There are two popular
SDKs in Japan right now,
one domestic and one overseas.
KEVIN CHIAO: That kind of
leads into my next question.
This will probably
be our last question,
but this is one from the
audience that was in the box.
We talked about
AdMob, and everyone
knows about user
acquisition, but they
are asking, what are
some non-paying ways
to promote your
apps on Google Play?
So without spending money
on user acquisition,
what are some ways to promote
your app on Google Play?
Video sharing can be
one of those, right?
KOH KIM: Video sharing,
building out communities.
Social media has actually been
a very interesting channel
for organic user acquisition,
mostly because it's
a lot closer to-- I think
video gamers tend to be very,
very engaged fans.
They like to share
their content,
they like to talk
about it, they like
to tell other people that
they should play their game
and a lot of stuff.
So social media becomes a
very interesting aspect,
and we're not just
talking video.
We're talking about all the
common places-- Twitter,
Facebook, even to some
extent G+ and all that stuff.
But really, it's knowing where
these users are congregating
and talking about your game.
And a lot of them
are just talking
about-- you see people
create their own fan sites
on the web about these games.
You see this with
"Call of Duty."
We see this with a lot
of the big console games.
I'm seeing a lot of this even
happening on the mobile side
as well.
And so building out
these communities,
building out your brand so that
people can interact with it,
but then they have
a forum and a place
to interact with
other players that
also enjoy the game
is going to become
a very powerful way to engage
users and empower them to talk.
KEVIN CHIAO: Do you
guys have anything
to add, non-paying ways?
KOH KIM: Besides featuring.
KEVIN CHIAO: Getting featured.
This is something we
didn't talk on a lot.
I think I drew about 10 of
these questions that said,
[SPEAKING CHINESE].
There is no definitive answer.
There is no, if
you do everything,
you will get featured list.
However, we do urge
everyone-- Tony touched on it
earlier in his core app quality
on developer.Android.com.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
Best practices.
So that's all we have for today.
Is Summer going to
come up and tell us
what's going to happen next?
Summer?
I think we're going to break the
wall down and have some drinks.
SUMMER: [SPEAKING CHINESE]